tout était en place pour une mission
sans fard et deux astronautes
l'américain aig et le russe alex
obstinée d'un vétéran sont montés à bord
souriant il faisait beau quand le
décompte a commencé un décollage parfait
des souris en plein vol alors que la
fusée s'apprêtait à entrer en orbite
dans la station spatiale
un signe de détresse a été lancée moteur
en panne
atterrissage d'urgence inévitable le
vaisseau a dû effectuer un retour sur
terre en mode balistique c'est à dire
presque en chute libre
c'est chute libre absolument pas tout
contrôler et c'est vraiment c'est comme
un crash de voitures quoi pour les
observateurs comme christine chapelle le
suspense a été court mais pénible de la
tour de contrôle à baïkonour jusqu'à la
nasa
c'était le silence radio la capitale a
fini par atterrir dans les steppes du
kazakhstan
les deux hommes sains et saufs mais ce
cui cui sont sous observation
ils sont en bonne forme le deuxième
l'astronaute canadien que sade field
pense surtout à ses confrères qui a
décla station spatiale depuis des mois
qui attend un autre et donc le sommes
seuls et personne ne sait combien temps
ils le resteront
ils ont un vaisseau qui peut en trois
heures les ramener sur terre
après si on veut renvoyer des
astronautes dans l'espace
là il faut qu'on trouve ce qui s'est
passé ce matin et on pensait pas on peut
pas faire repartir une fusée le
gouvernement russe a suspendu tous les
vols habités jusqu'à nouvel ordre
le prochain était prévue le 20 décembre
il devait transporter le canadien david
saint jacques qui était à baïkonour ce
matin à titre de doublure pour
l'équipage qui a échoué
la ville de baie saint jean j'ai changé
aujourd'hui
et c'est l'avenir de la station spatiale
qui est en jeu dit cet expert
c'est la première fois depuis l'an 2000
que la possibilité que la station
spatiale soient désertés inoccupés est
bien réelle carla soyouz est non
seulement la fusée la plus fiable de
l'histoire elle est aujourd'hui la seule
qui peut transporter des humains vers la
station internationale
les russes devront maintenant rassuré
leurs partenaires comme la nasa mais
l'incident d'aujourd'hui mais aussi
énormément de pression sur des
compagnies comme boeing qui tarde à
livrer la prochaine génération de fusées
aux américains tamara alter eco radio
canada moscow